[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend und Willkommen an
diesem 11.11 Fußball und Wintersport hat
gleich Norbert Lehmann ein schön guten
Abend auch von mir und das sind die
Nachrichtenthemen von
heute kein Strom keine Versorgung das
größte Krankenhaus im G Streifen stellt
nach eigenen Angaben den Betrieb ein
doch nicht alle Patienten könnten die
Klinik verlassen Ringen um eine
diplomatische Lösung Außenministerin
bbock verhandelt im Nahen Osten und in
Riad treffen sich arabische und
muslimische
Länder und Feiern in schwierigen Zeiten
tausende leiten in den Karnevals und
fasnachtshochburgen die fünte Jahreszeit
ein die medizinische Versorgung im Gaza
Streifen wird immer schwieriger nach
Angaben der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation
funktionieren die meisten der insgesamt
36 Krankenhäuser nicht mehr heute musste
offenbar auch die größte Klinik in dem
abgeriegelten Küstenstreifen ihren
Betrieb einstellen weil kein Treibstoff
mehr da ist sagt die Hamas Israel
widerspricht aus Tel Aviv Stefan
leifert die Dunkelheit der Nacht zeigt
besonders klar wie heftig der Beschuss
auf Gaza ist aufgenommen von
israelischer Seite in der Nacht zum
Samstag das Vorgehen der israelischen
Armee konzentriert sich heute auf das
alschifer Krankenhaus das größte im
Gazastreifen unter dem Gebäude soll die
Hamas ein Kommando und Kontrollzentrum
betreiben das hier ist mehr Kampfzone
als Krankenhaus es ist eine
gespenstische Atmosphäre die
Bombardierungen dauern nun seit über 24
Stunden ohne Unterbrechung an vom Boden
aus der
Luft laut israelischenem Militär haben
50.000 Menschen den Norden des
Gazastreifens verlassen auf dem Gelände
des Krankenhauses reih die die noch da
sind die Opfer eininander premier
Netanyahu besucht zum Schabbat die
israelischen Soldaten und beschwört
deren
Kampfkraft wir hatten sehr sehr
schwierige Tage aber ihr wisst warum wir
das alles machen unsere Kämpfer werden
den Feind
zerstören auch der Norden Israels ist
heute wieder Kampfzone das Militär
veröffentlicht Videos die Luftschläge
gegen hisbolla Ziele im Libanon zeigen
sollen hisbollachef NAS raller richtet
seine Warnungen erneut an die
USA wer möchte dass dieser Krieg nicht
zu einem Krieg der ganzen Region wird
muss den Krieg in Gaza stoppen und wenn
die USA wollen dass die Operationen
gegen sie aufhören müssen sie den Krieg
in Gaza
stoppen in Tel Aviv versammeln sich am
Abend Tausende in Solidarität mit den
Angehörigen der rund 240 hamasgeiseln
die Traumabewältigung eines ganzen
Landes geht
weiter Außenministerin berbock versucht
zu vermitteln sie ist zum dritten Mal
seit dem Terrorangriff der Hamas im
Nahen Osten es geht vor allem darum
humanitäre Hilfe zu ermöglichen und die
Geiseln zu befreien bei den Gesprächen
mit Vertretern aus Katar und
Saudi-Arabien ging auch um die Chancen
für einen Frieden und um die
Perspektiven für eine
Zweistaatenlösung anschließend reiste
die Außenministerin weiter in die
palästinensischen Autonomiegebiete im
Westjordanland und nach Tel Aviv Daniel
ponzen begleitet die Reise und ist uns
jetzt aus Tel Aviv live von der
Pressekonferenz der Außenministerin
zugeschaltet Daniel was ist das
bisherige Fazit dieser Reise gerade auch
nach dem Besuch in den
Palästinensergebieten ja dass sich die
Lage nicht etwa entspannt hat sondern
weiter angespannt hat wie sie gerade
auch noch mal bei der Pressekonferenz
hier deutlich gemacht hat die
Außenministerin versuchte die gemäßten
Kräfte im arabischen Raum zu stärken
aber diese Kräfte haben deutlich gemacht
bei den Gesprächen dass es immer
schwerer auch wird für Sie diese
Vermittlerrolle einzunehmen angesichts
der sich zuspitzenden Lage in Gaza eine
Lage die sich nun auf keinen Fall
fortsetzen dürf übergreifen dürf aus
Westjordanland das war die zentrale
Botschaft Ihres Besuchs dort in R
ramalla auch das Signal sollte davon
ausgehen erneut wir sehen auch euer leid
das Leid der
Palästinenser sie hat auch sehr scharf t
durch radikale jüdische Siedler dort im
westjland verurteilt hat allerdings
zugleich jedem Statement auch gerade
hier noch mal deutlich gemacht dass die
alleinige Schuld an der jüngsten
Eskalation die hamass trägt vom mit dem
Terrorangriff vom 7 Oktober der hier in
Tel Aviv natürlich noch sehr stark
Nachhalt vor allem bei den Angehörigen
der Geiseln und der Ermordeten zwei von
ihnen wird sie gleich treffen nach den
politischen Gesprächen die hier in
wenigen Minuten beginnen vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung von der
Pressekonferenz der Außenministerin aus
Tel Aviv danke schön Daniel
Punzen um über den Krieg in Gaza und
mögliche Lösungen zu beraten hat
Saudi-Arabien die arabischen und
muslimischen Länder zu einem
Sondergipfel in Riad eingeladen mehr als
55 Staaten waren dabei Jordanien die
Türkei und Katar genauso wie Syrien und
Israels Erzfeind Iran dessen Präsident
raisi sagte wir küssen der Hamas die
Hände für ihren Widerstand gegen Israel
goline atai berichtet zwei Gipfel an
einem Ort mit dabei die Staatschefs der
islamischen Länder und diejenigen der
arabischen Länder sowohl usverbündete
wie Jordaniens König Abdallah als auch
iranhörige wie syriens Machthaber
Baschar
al-Assad ein historischer Moment
erstmals geben sich irans Präsident
raisi und der saudische Kronprinz
binalman an die Hand einst politische
Feinde so viele Differenzen auf einen
Nenner zu bringen ein schier unmögliches
Unterfangen doch der Schärfe des
saudischen Gastgebers schließen sich
viele hier an sie fordern einen
sofortigen echten Waffenstillstand in
Gaza wir erleben eine humanitäre
Katastrophe sie zeigt sich im Scheitern
des un Sicherheitsrates und der
internationalen Gemeinschaft die
ungeheuerlichen Verstöße Israels gegen
das Völkerrecht zu
beenden irans Präsident geht noch weiter
in einer propagandistischen Rede die den
Saal mobilisieren soll verlangt er
Waffenlieferungen für die Palästinenser
und
mehr wir fordern den Abbruch aller
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen mit dem zionistischen Regime
und einen Handels und
energiebott doch damit bleibt Reis
allein weder Saudiarabien noch die
Emirate Folgen solchen extremen am Ende
verkündet der saudische Außenminister
nur eine minimale
Einigung eine Kerngruppe soll
politischen Druck erzeugen um weitere
Waffenlieferungen an Israel zu
verhindern und die zwei staatenlösung
voranzutreiben in verschiedenen Städten
in Deutschland hat es heute wieder
solidaritätsdemonstrationen für die
Palästinenser gegeben sowie hier in
Wuppertal etwa 2000 Menschen protesti
unter strengen Auflagen und überwiegend
friedlich gegen das israelische Vorgehen
in
Gaza ganz andere Dimensionen in London
dort gab es heute wieder einen riesigen
Demonstrationszug dabei ist in
Großbritannien heute eigentlich der
wichtigste Gedenktag für die Opfer der
Weltkriege über den brisanten Tag in der
britischen Hauptstadt Hilke
Petersen sie ehren die Toten der Kriege
ein großer und wichtiger Jahrestag für
Großbritannien Schweigeminuten quer
durchs
Land dabei gestört zu werden die
Befürchtung löste er bitterten Streit
aus denn auch ein proalästiner Marsch
zieht heute durch London wie an den
vergangenen vier Wochenenden doch so
viele kamen noch nie mehr als 300.000 so
die Polizei die britische
Innenministerin Zella bravan hatte die
Proteste hassmärsche
genannt provokante Rhetorik ist ihr Stil
der eigenen Polizei sie vor
Gesetzesbrüche proalästinensischer
Kräfte zu
ignorieren beim großen Marsch durch
London unterschiedliche
gesellschaftliche Gruppen und ihre
Forderungen ihr seht eine diverse
Mischung von Menschen alle treten ein
für
Menschenrechte Kinder dürfen nicht
sterben wir brauchen
Waffenstillstand das ist kein hassmarsch
hier ist jeder für
Frieden die Strecke einige Kilometer
entfernt vom Ort des nationalen Krieg
Gedenkens das schützen zu wollen hatte
Rechte gegen Demonstranten
aufmarschieren lassen mehr als 90
Nationalisten und Hooligans werden
festgenommen der Vorwurf an die
Innenministerin steht im Raum die
Rechten ideologisch aufgestachelt zu
haben jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine
erstmals seit Wochen hat Russland wieder
die Hauptstadt Kiev angegriffen größere
Schäden und Verletzte gab es laut
ukrainischen Behörden nicht auch aus
anderen Landes Teilen wurden Angriffe
gemeldet besonders umkämpft ist nach wie
vor avdiivga im Gebiet donetk Polizisten
fordern die verbliebenen Bewohner auf
sich in Sicherheit zu bringen die Stadt
wird laut Militärverwaltung quasi rund
um die Uhr
beschossen im Südwesten Islands bebt
seit Tagen die Erde für Experten ein
Zeichen dass es bald einen vulkanusbruch
gibt die Behörden auf der Atlantikinsel
haben eine sogenannte Gefahrenlage
ausgerufen tausende Erdstöße erschüttern
seit knapp zweieinhalb Wochen die
Halbinsel rekanes unweit der Hauptstadt
rekjawik der Ort grindawig wurde
vorsorglich evakuiert das bei
touristenbeliebte Thermalbad Blaue
Lagune geschlossen wiinhescher
berichtet so bebt die Erde seit fast
zwei Wochen tausende Male kurz aber
heftig im Südwesten Islands was im
Erdinneren los ist zeigt sich oberhalb
Risse gräb und meterbreite Spalten mir
sind die Sachen aus dem Regal geknallt
ich rante nur noch im Kreis um irgendwie
alles
festzuhalten in der Nacht wurde der
kleine Ort grindawig keine 30 km
entfernt von rjawig evakuiert niemandem
ist etwas passiert aber die Sorge dass
etwas passiert nimmt stetig
zu alles was wir an Daten haben zeigt
dass unter der Erde die Magma Korridore
und der Fluss des Magmas größer werden
und ein Ausbruch nah Zukunft immer
wahrscheinlicher
wird im Südwesten Islands war es schon
in den vergangenen dre Jahren zu Vulkan
Ausbrüchen gekommen immer nach längeren
erdbebenserien leider betrifft es jetzt
eine Region die eben besiedelt ist und
in der relativ viel Infrastruktur an
angesiedelt ist die blaue Lagune wurde
vorsorglich geschlossen nah dran auch
das Geothermiekraftwerk das den
Flughafen in regjawig versorgt die
evakuierten Menschen in grinderwig
nehmen es auf ihre isländische Art
niemand zu Hause wir machen
vulkanurlaub jetzt ein Blick ins
Deutsche Historische Museum in Berlin da
widmet sich eine Ausstellung dem
Liedermacher und Lyriker Wolf Biermann
Biermann war einer der schärfsten
regimkritiker in der DDR seine
ausbürgerin Ausbürgerung
1976 löste in West und Ost Empörung aus
heute war Wolf Biermann selbst vor Ort
und das Interesse an ihm und seiner
Geschichte war groß Christ hat
lepple ganz neue Töne von Wolf Biermann
sein Gedicht von den Menschen als Rap
präsentiert von HipHopper Torch im
Deutschen Historischen
museumishit ein bralles Berliner
Wochenende für den Liedermacher Wolf
Biermann Konzerte Filme und Führungen
für eine lebende Legende nun mehr fast
87 Jahre alt und kein bisschen leise
es lohnt sich sich einzumischen in die
eigenen Angelegenheiten und sich zu
wehren gegen das Unrecht zu sehen sind
21 Objekte eines bewegten Lebens von der
berühmten Konzertgitarre bis zur
abhörwaner der gebürtige Hamburger ein
streitbarer und wortgewaltiger Chronist
der deutschen Teilung im Osten verfolgt
und verschwiegen im Westen viel gehört
und
gefeiert sehr charismatische Art zu
erzählen das hat mich begeistert ist für
mich auf jeden Fall einer der
wichtigsten
Zeitgenossen meines Lebens ich habe ihn
dann auch live gesehen und fand ihn als
Persönlichkeit auch sehr imponierend
einfach mit einer sehr großen
Ausstrahlung in der Ausstellung können
Kinder ihre Wünsche zeichnen i love
Biermann free Palestine Wolf dieses Bild
gefällt Biermann ganz besonders wenn ich
das lese denke
ich dieses Wort ist leider unvollkommen
müsste stehen free
Palestine von
Hamas das Biermann Wochenende in Berlin
gefeiert wird ein Mann der Geschichte
geschrieben hat übrigens die Ausstellung
wird bis zum 2 juni 204
verlängert und dann war ja dann noch was
heute traditionell am 11.11 geliebt von
den einen kopfschüttelnd beeugt von den
anderen um 11:1 Uhr ging es los vor
allem in den fasnachs Hochburgen meainz
Düsseldorf und Köln Jan Hofer hat
mehr es geht wieder los laut fröhlich
und bunt schon am Vormittag sind hier in
der Kölner Altstadt zetausende Jecken
auf den Straßen
unterwegs wir freuen uns natürlich mega
das ist endlich wieder losgeht oder
endlich wieder super voll ist und alle
Spaß haben feiern sollen wir auf jeden
Fall wir müssen ja irgendwie wieder
Kräfte sammeln und motivieren für die
Welt da draußen weil der 11 in diesem J
WN Samstag fällt und die Sonne scheint
erleben karnevalshochbogen wie Köln
einen echten Ansturm besonders beliebte
feiermeilen sind schon vormittags wegen
Überfüllung gesperrt die Stadt hat eine
Ausweichfläche so groß wie vier
Fußballfelder vorbereitet für die die
nirgendwo reinkommen für die Polizei ein
Großeinsatz wir haben bisher immer mal
wieder ein bisschen Druck an
sperrstellen da unterstützen wir dann
die Stadt die Ordner und die
Sicherheitskräfte aber bisher ist die
Bilanz dessen was wir haben einige
wenige Körper Verletzung
beleidigungsdelikte Sachbeschädigung
aber ist alles noch im Rahmen die größte
Synagoge der Stadt liegt zudem mitten in
einem Party Hotspot um sie hat die
Polizei eine Schutzzone errichtet es ist
ein 11.1 in unruhigen
Zeiten und jetzt Wintersportsaison
Auftakt im Slalom der Frauen ja im
finnischen Levi und den hat die Slowakin
Petra willova souverän gewonnen vor Lena
D die eine Superleistung zeigte die
Münchnerin steht damit zum zehnten Mal
in ihrer Karriere auf dem
Podest es war der erhoffte gute
saisonauftagt für Lena D auf einer ihrer
lieblingspisten im Weltcup die WM dritte
mit einer überzeugenden Leistung in
beiden Läufen als zweitbeste geht sie in
den Finaldurchgang wo sie Nervenstärke
und technische Präzision beweist
spitzenfahrerinnen wie usstar Mikaela
schifffrin oder die Schwedin Sarah
Hektor verweist sie auf die Plätze nur
eine fährt heute wie in einer anderen
Liga Petra willowa baut ihren
vorsprungaus Lauf 1 von 18h immer weiter
aus die Olympiasiegerin aus der Slowakei
gewinnt mit unglaublichen 1,41 Sekunden
vor Lena D und der Österreicherin
Katharina lensberger Lena D aber hat
eindrucksvoll gezeigt dass auch in
diesem Winter wieder mit ihr zu rechnen
ist zur Fußball buundesliga da hat
Bayern Heidenheim besiegt und die
Tabellenführung übernommen hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse des 11 Spieltags
München gegen starke he Heimer 4:2
Augsburg und Hoffenheim trennen sich 1:1
Stuttgart besiegt Dortmund hochverdient
mit 2:1 der Siegtreffer durch den
wiedergenesenen girassi Darmstadt und
Mainz 0:0 in einem niveauarmen Duell und
das Abendspiel Bochum gegen Köln bereits
gestern besiegte Gladbach W Wolfsburg
souverän mit 4:0 Blick auf die Tabelle
München zumindest für eine nach
Tabellenführer Leverkusen kann morgen
wieder vorbeiziehen Stuttgart festig den
dritten Platz vor Dortmund
dann Leipzig und Hoffenheim die zweite
Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit Augsburg und
am Tabellenende Mainz durch den Punkt
Gewinn jetzt 16 dahinter Union und Köln
das Abendspiel Bochum gegen Köln
ausfühlich bei uns zu sehen im Aktuellen
Sportstudio 23 Uhr zu Gast vbstürmer
Dennis underf und Tennisspielerin Laura
Siegemund im ersten Halbfinale des iF
superglobs haben die Füchse überraschend
Barcelona besiegt die Berliner
Handballer setzt nach Verlängerung knapp
mit 35 z34 durch Jubel bei den Füchsen
Berlin der Traum vom Titel bei der Club
WM lebt es ist ein harter Kampf mit dem
FC Barcelona um den Einzug ins Finale
dabei wird der Junge füchsetorhüter
lasse Ludwig in der regulären Spielzeit
10 Sekunden vor Schluss zum Helden
pariert den 7 me der Katalan und rettet
Berlin in die Verlängerung der beste
Werfer der Partie Matas g bent zum
Siegtreffer schließende Freiwurf des FC
Barcelona keine Gefahr für Berlin die
Füchse zeigen Kampfgeist und sorgen für
eine große Überraschung mit dem Sieg
über das spanische Topteam und im
zweiten Halbfinale spielt gerade
Magdeburg gegen kelze könnte also ein
deutsches Finale gehen ja toll drück mir
die Daumen es gab schon ein bisschen
Schnee in den Höhenlagen er wird sich
wohl nicht lange halten denn es kommt
Regen und es wird milder Details hat
gleich Katja hornfer um 11: Uhr meldet
sich Marietta Slomka mit dem heute
journal wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen
schönen Samstagabend und sind morgen
wieder da wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend auch wenn es heute
in den mittelgebirg mal etwas geschneit
hat für die meisten von uns dominieren
doch derzeit noch die Herbstfarben das
sieht in den Alpen anders aus da hat es
zum Teil ja schon kräftig geschneit und
morgen können in der Schweiz erhalb von
2000 m durchaus 50 cm neuschneefallen
dann aber kommt von Westen kräftiger
Regen heran und bis Montagabend können
innerhalb von 48 Stunden im Allgäu bis
zu 100 l Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen
die Wasserstände von kleineren Bächen
und Flüssen in Süddeutschland werden
also ansteigen heute Nacht fällt kaum
Regen zum einen hier im Norden aber auch
am Alpenrand da ist do noch etwas Schnee
dabei sonst ist es trocken und die
Temperaturen sinken auf + 7 bis -3° die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 4 und 10° im Nordosten kann es
morgen noch etwas regnen sonst aber
wird's ganz freundlich zwischen dem
Emsland und dem Erzgebirge und der Donau
da zeigt sich immer mal wieder die Sonne
zwischen den Wolken anders sieht im
Südwesten aus da kommen die neuen
Regenwolken heran und anfänglich ist
auch Schnee dabei und sehr wechselhaft
stürmisch mit viel Regen und mild
beginnt dann die neue Woche bei 6 bis
15° schönes W
Ende